it's time for cruise news your daily
soak in the good news tub and with me at
the desk is malwa rubber ducky rosie
ross matthew hi
all right let's hit a few headlines here
because we all need some good news
interesting pop culture and fun facts
about our world and we're kicking it off
with something super steamy this morning
people magazine just revealed their
sexiest man alive
i don't know if you loved him from
clueless or his cut off jeans and wet
hot american summer or that bushy stash
and anchorman like he is deserving i
love when like because to me sexy is
nice yeah and funny and he's funny yeah
he's funny and
so i keep
listen you can't i keep shaking and ross
matthews is not in here anywhere but
you are the sexiest man to me rossi tell
people that i will you know we have some
very handsome um sexy men in this
audience rossi did you know that uh oh
yeah i noticed can we say hi to great
group or andrew spencer can i say hi to
you right over here
from the bachelorette um how are you
guys today and what are you doing here
we're so excited you are here
um
we're huge fans of you yeah yeah
are you single yeah yeah
yeah
it's like it's like coughing season
right now so we're definitely like you
know very well looking so you're you're
you're looking to cough
exactly holiday coziness
yeah and i'm just curious if there are
any single women in the audience here
today oh look there there's someone
raising him
so oh my gosh there's someone out there
who just said oh my god mom stop it
cause she was making a razor on him oh
my god i'm just saying my daughter is
very genuine very single and
very passionate she is actually going
for nursing school
interesting
well i would just tell it i was just
telling him before we haven't had coffee
yet so if you want to come down
oh there's a great little place around
the corner can we send you to rex coffee
after this yes most definitely all right
[Applause]
we are celebrating beauty week here on
the show so we've got to talk about the
latest makeup trend now when it comes to
blush the zoe report says move over pink
it's purple time oh yeah that's right
the most royal color of them all is
popping up on cheeks everywhere check
out these purple looks uh see look the
blush purple i'm pretty into this you
like the purple blush well i just love
beauty trends they're fun you know they
are fun but i would worry that i would
look too much like gem in the holograms
with purple blush you remember that um i
do okay so um here is a fun new tip that
i learned about blush placement
um it's really interesting um mian chan
uh
taught it to me
okay you put it here
because it actually lifts your eye it's
like an insta facelift should i try it
naturally yeah me anne i love you
not great
i did a little heavy on this side
i like it all right next we've got a
pick from our little yellow book which
is my personal curation of things that i
would love you to know about
it's a beautiful organization to follow
and support america's vet dogs this
incredible group trains and places
service and guide dogs with vets and
first responders who have served this
country with dignity and they help
people who have injuries ptsd or hearing
and vision loss and all of their work is
100 free to their clients
you can get all of their information and
find out how you can support their work
on our website at the drewberrymart
show.com i think it might be my favorite
little yellow
[Music]